we all remember that
day for
some the pain will never
fade when I was a kid I always wanted to
be my
dad what if that
happens what if I become him and I don't
even know
him I need to do more I can save
lives put me back out
there Mark isn't like other V mon he's a
good guy dinner tonight go save the
world Invincible you're way too good for
me who are you I call me the shapes
Smith there's an infinite number of
dimensions and I was born with the
ability to access all of
them shut it down or I take it down make
us you have no idea how much I wanted
you to say that it's B in I'mma let it
man i' through
War your powers don't make you a hero
they make you
dangerous make him pay for what he did
to your world the last 20 years of my
life have been alive you want this back
come and get it wrong choice
I need
Revenge so arrogant just like your
father people of Earth the more you
resist the worse this
gets and if you think you can stop us
don't forget
[Music]
I'm